- I love a good collaboration y'all
and my next guests are
Grammy winning country stars
who are set to release an
album of great collaborations
on November 13th, which is a great day
'cause it's my sister's birthday.
It's called "Every Road" here we go.
I grew up on these guys.
What!
Please, welcome Marty
Raybon, and Mike McGuire
from Shenandoah.
(audience cheering)
Also welcome the awesome band
who joined them for one of
the tracks on their album,
Hillary Scott, Dave
Haywood, and Charles Kelley
from Lady A, give it up!
(audience cheering)
What's up y'all!
- Hi.
- I miss Nashville.
It is so great to see you.
It's been a long, long time actually,
since I've seen y'all, I feel like.
- Yes, it has.
I feel like a couple of years.
I think probably it's been
too long. We missed ya.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
I feel like-
- Probably, when we made that
tribute to Reba McEntire, right?
- Maybe, yeah, that's what I was thinking.
Maybe it is that, Yeah.
And I guess we always run
into each other's shows.
Yeah, yeah.
How's Kelly doing Dave?
- Ah, she's good. She says hello.
I know last time we were hanging out,
we were playing pool against
you at a dinner party.
But we're doing good, hanging in there.
- I know.
And I actually saw y'all video.
Y'all are doing videos together
and you're so hysterical.
- [Dave] That's my wife and I.
- You in for funniest couple.
(laughs)
- [Dave] Ah, thank you.
We've gotten very bored.
- It entertained me for
a long time, my friend.
Well, Jamie and Kristen are
y'all country music fans?
Jamie, I'll start with you.
- Oh, yes. Are you kidding?
I married a musician?
You'd know.
(Kelly laughs)
Well, no, but I mean, no, no.
I'm saying he did a
different kind of music.
I mean, he was known for spinal tap
and being sort of a fake rock guitars,
but he's a classical musician
and yes, devoted to music.
In fact, if you haven't
seen it, everybody,
the PBS Ken Burns country
music documentary series,
is one of the greatest experiences
you will ever have in your entire lives.
- Agreed. Agreed.
I love that you saw that.
- I agree, I watched that,
that was spot on.
- Kristen, do you like
you're in Nashville now.
- Exactly, I tell what,
being in Nashville now
for about eight years,
I've learned to start
loving country music.
Didn't think I would ever be that girl,
but I am a big fan now (laughs).
- Yes. They'll suck you in.
It's the lifestyle too.
Everybody it's so nice.
So Jamie, is it true that you
once wrote a country song?
I heard that you maybe wrote one.
- I may have written a country music song.
It may be called "Don't
Treat Your Man Too Rough".
It's sort of a-
(Kelly laughs)
It's a little bit about like,
we need to like give them a bit of a break
because we re bro beat them a bit.
You know what Kelly?
I'm gonna send it to you,
off air I will send it to you
and see maybe we can collaborate.
- Okay. And maybe at the end
they can twist and be like,
nah, nevermind I was right.
(laughs)
So Mike and Marty,
tell us about the new album "Every Road".
I think I saw, did Blake Shelton,
did he tweet about it, he's on it as well?
- Yeah, Blake Shelton (indistinct).
- Yeah, that's cool.
- It literally is a,
it's a collaboration record where
Dierks Bentley is on it.
Cody Johnson from Texas,
a buddy of ours that we met down there,
Brad Paisley's on it.
We got Ashley McBryde.
She's a part of it, part of the peers.
You know, it's just a record that really,
it was something that we wanted to do
as far as trying to do a record
and to invite people to be a part of it.
But we didn't wanna do a record
that was the greatest hits.
- Yeah.
- Like in other words,
you know, everybody come over
and do "Two Dozen Roses" with us.
Everybody come to "Church
on Cumberland Road".
We wanted to have new material
because this actually is
the first record we'd done
in 20 years that we've had,
the end of the whole album,
it's all new material.
- Yeah.
- And the first time I
believe it's ever been done
with guests artists.
And the great thing about
what Lady A had sent us,
they had sent us the tune
that they had written
and that was a wonderful piece of music.
And when we cut the tracks
and got the vocals on it,
and then all of a sudden
when the Lady A put their
vocals on there as well,
mainly just listened to it.
It make you take back
stuff you ain't stole.
I mean, them cats can forever more sing.
I mean they just can
and this whole album literally
it's literally a gathering
of that type of material.
- I love, that's my
favorite kind of record.
That's what I grew up on.
And so I'm really excited about it.
Lady, how'd y'all get involved?
- Yeah, we did that show
and I kinda geeked out
on these guys, honestly.
I mean, we grew up on this music
and I'm not gonna lie,
I had a little bit of
a real big fan moment backstage
and Marty said, "Hey, we're
gonna be working on a record.
"We should do some, you know,
we should exchange numbers."
And he never let up. And it was great.
And then you just started
kinda snowballing,
'cause that's one of
the things you can have
these conversations,
but for it to really come together
in to fruition
in the way that they got
all these amazing artists,
I mean, we really feel
blessed to be a part of it.
So this is a really cool
project to be a part of.
I think it could literally,
just knowing the other
artists that are on it,
this could be a Grammy winning
collaboration project
and I'm just so proud
of being a part of it.
- Yeah.
I can only imagine too,
like being such a fan of it.
I grew up on Shenandoah too.
So, I can't imagine being
such a fan of someone
and then getting to do that.
I mean I can, I got to do
that actually with Reba
who's one of my favorite people.
But it's such a different feeling,
especially you wrote the
song that they're singing,
which is what y'all did as well.
It's such a different feeling
of like, "Oh my gosh."
It's like it doesn't matter
everything that's happened.
This is like such a cool
moment for 10 year old me.
And it's just a really
cool thing to be on such
a cool collaborative project
that you'll put together.
So Lady A and Shenandoah
are gonna perform later
in the show.
(audience cheering)
Shenandoah's new album
"Every Road" is out November
13th, my sister's birthday.
It's a great day.